we talk ourselves into a a worse story
that is safer so that we feel better
about not having gone so if you're what
do you you know if you had a genie and
you could just wish for the kind of life
you wanted or the kind of change you
wanted to make or the kind of family you
wanted whatever it is
um
no don't be scared what is it what is
that you know maybe you're not going to
get it all you probably won't but like
don't don't be scared to look at it
don't be like uh depressed to even
thinking about just look at it right and
then start to think about what now what
does it tell what why have I not gone
for that whatever it is why am I not
going
and assess that because that is so often
is that your brain mistakenly because
it's up in nut step five of risk and
your brain uh mistakenly
um is is is your your ear is treating
that like real danger it's it's
incorrectly delusionally irrationally
treating that like real danger when the
fact is you're actually the suffering
you're having from not doing the thing
you want to do is real and that is
taking a toll on you
and you're taking that toll as a heavy
cost to avoid what is not actually risky
but seems risky to us like like failure
potential failure or embarrassment or
reputational damage or you know maybe
having some hard financial years
um
ask yourself
is that it are those things worse than
the there you have a you have a positive
that's if things go badly right there's
maybe those things happen
and maybe you you achieve your dreams
you get the thing you really want
as instead of saying because I don't
want to take the chance of the negative
outcome there I'm going to take a
hundred percent chance of kind of living
with uh yearning and a little bit of
sadness and a little bit of envy and
maybe a lot of those things and a little
bit of bitterness
and you know it's like that's real that
sucks that's human pain like you're
accepting a lot of pain to avoid the
other potential human pain but at least
there there's the upside of it so
you know it's always very personal
everyone for some people embarrassment
is way way way worse than
pain than
um then Envy or
you know bitterness ever could be for
some I think for a lot of people
embarrassment seems so much worse than
it actually is when it happens or you
know whatever you know so I get
criticism rejection just seems so scary
to us because we think we're in a tribe
A long time ago and then it happens and
Sky doesn't fall and then you're a
little stronger because now you don't
you're not scared of it as much in the
future it's so interesting that you make
that point because we're both when we
started this we're both stand-up
comedians and a lot of people would say
doing stand-up is one of their greatest
fears actually and that is it's so
liberating doing it because you know
particularly when you start out you're
by definition not very good so you you
have times when you tell a joke and no
one laughs and to most people that is
the scariest thing possible and
comedians even call it dying when you
don't do well at a gig we call it dying
but actually when it happens it's an
incredibly liberating because you
realize it's nowhere near as bad as you
thought
I had a friend who was a kind of amateur
comedian and actually one night went out
and bombed on purpose like was just just
to say this is the worst thing that can
happen
you got some booze with some silence and
he left he was like was that was that so
bad no it's not it's not a big deal
right
um and uh and and so you know sometimes
you have to
um you can't just tell yourself
something's like you have to show
yourself you have to actually do it and
then
um
and then uh it can you know standard
comedian you know anything are artistic
uh you know and movies you know somebody
wants to make movies they want to make
music they want to
um they want to write a book people are
so scared to write fiction especially
um including me by the way I I'd love to
write fiction but it's ah
um and uh and you know public speaking
of course you know people avoid whole
careers they avoid you know ambition
being ambitious at work because if they
get a promotion they're gonna have to
speak in public more you know I mean
um and and uh and so there's so many
examples like this and in each case uh
your brain is not being very wise it's
actually it's actually like
um it's it's like you know it's like a
little kid it's like hiding under a
blanket because I think there's a
monster there it's not much wiser than
that and then you know you get older and
you say all that it's cute of course
kids think there's March that are scared
of the dark
um it's not actually but then we do this
in our own way human adults do the same
exact thing there's a great line in my
favorite TV show the British office
um
I'm so glad that you said that there's
so many Americans I know who search the
American office and they should all burn
in hell for that sorry thank you it's I
like the American office but it's a show
it's another good show it is the UK
office is the best show ever made in
history I completely agree whenever you
want to come back on the show you're
more than welcome to okay
so there's a line where Tim who's a
great character he's kind of the the
relatable the relatable character he
says
you know he has this he he he hates his
life he hates his job he knows he should
be doing something different than
selling paper
and he's you know he's a he's a clever
guy he could do a lot in the world and
he you know he's building up courage
he's saying yep I'm going to quit and he
kind of does and then you know that that
fear that irrational fear kicks in and
suddenly he's back at the job and the
the you know the the mockumentary crew
asks him why and he says well you know
if you look at life like uh rolling a
dice then my situation now as it stands
yeah it may only be a three
if I jack that in now go for something
bigger and better yeah I could easily
roll a six no problem I could roll a six
I could also roll a one
Okay so
I think sometimes just leave the dice
alone
you know and it's again it's so
depressing right but so many of us think
that way so many of us think that way
where uh like you said the avoidance of
discomfort we will take you know if
you're actually truly comfortable
that's fine I don't think people should
feel like oh that's not enough but what
does comfort mean Comfort isn't just
that you have the mean you know
financial means and
um that things are kind of easy it also
means you're comfortable in your brain
you feel good about life you feel good
about the world you wake up in the
morning and you like where you are right
that's real Comfort okay I think that's
great a lot of people they what they're
thinking of as comfort and avoiding
discomfort when they're actually in a
tremendous amount of discomfort already
because they don't feel like they're
living the right kind of life
um so again it's it's always assessing
like people don't like to think people
ignore this Factor when they're thinking
about the oh you know that this change
they could make they forget they're not
factoring in the cost that they're
experiencing every day right now uh by
not doing the thing and and by the way
it's not just for you it's not just a
selfish narcissistic discussion to be
having it's
you know if you're if you go out and do
something that you know you really want
to do the world is better off if you do
it you know you're you're depriving the
world of your gift if you're not doing
that or you know likewise if you're not
in the best relationship and so many
people aren't
um you can stay in it forever because
nothing seems scarier to our primitive
brains than going off on our own and
what if I don't find someone and all
everyone's going to talk about my
divorce or my breakup and then it's
going to be conflict and so we'll just
stay in it forever meanwhile like you're
not doing the person any favors or
anyone you know when you hang out with
other people you depress people you know
when you're not a great kid you are
doing so much more for the world if you
go out and get yourself into a better
kind of relationship um you're you're
it's better for your family it's better
for your friends it's better for that
person and for the your ex as well
foreign